hey everyone Mary here with a gamespot  news update mirrors edge 2 is now  officially called Mirror's Edge catalyst  after a few rumors on social media and  the listing on European intellectual  property site earlier this week EA and  dice have officially confirmed the title  for the first person parkour game  catalysts senior producer Sarah Danson  stresses that Mirror's Edge catalyst is  not a sequel she said we've landed on a  vision that honors the first game  pushing the boundaries of first-person  movement and diving deeper into the  story behind our heroine faith catalyst  is scheduled to release during ea's  fourth fiscal quarter so sometime  between january and march 2016 it's  expected to release for console and PC  though an official list of platforms has  not yet been announced with e3 right  around the corner hopefully we'll get a  glimpse of faith in action for more news  and all III coverage be sure to head to  gamespot com